uh welcome everyone thanks for coming
always nice to see people here on a you
know first day tutorial for the morning
uh I'm Gil fory this is pH of cloud
we're going to be doing this tutorial on
ivis um just a quick temperature check
who here has heard of IIs versus just
wandered into the room okay 5050 sweet
so we we'll go over what IIs is very
quickly and then we'll Dive In um how
many of you work with um databases just
like at work you got to pull data from
something yeah how many of you really
love
SQL that's totally fine if you do that's
not a bad question yeah okay just just
you know taking the T that's fine um
great um so there are we're going to be
uh going off of this uh repo here it has
a few dup or notebooks in it um so if
you haven't already please take this
time to go to this website um this is i-
project- tututorial
um clone that and create an environment
using your tool of Joy um we're also
happy to circulate and help troubleshoot
environment issues get get you set up or
you can create a code Space by clicking
this blue button and clicking create Cod
space on Main that is also an option if
you're having local setup issues um and
then I will talk for a few minutes about
what IIs is and what we're going to try
to cover and then we'll just dive into
it um another note is that we're going
to do uh sort of carpentry light Style
on this so Philip's going to hand out
Post-it notes uh to everybody you got a
single Post-It note and that's just for
when we're doing exercises like little
you know interactive exercises I'll ask
that when you are finished with that
exercise you put the posted note just up
on your laptop just on the outside it's
a quick way for me to visually gauge how
many of you were done instead of just
asking impossible questions like is
everyone finished uh and getting useful
information back so that's those are for
um and then otherwise feel free to
interrupt at any point raise hands um
just shout at me all these things work
your your your style of communication is
welcome
um and with that I think we'll take
off I promise there are not very many
slides
um should put that up for the L anyway
IIs it's a
bird otherwise affectionally refer to
his bitten chickens in Australia uh they
eat out of dumpsters that's not we're
about here unless your data is a dump
we're going to come back to that analogy
um I'm G for assisted today by Philip
Cloud we both work at Voltron data uh I
am one of the IIs maintainers Philip is
the lead developer and maintainer um and
uh these are places you can find us on
the internet um I don't really post much
I just like stalk people on Macedon
Philip does roughly weekly live streams
usually IIs related it's a great Channel
highly recommend it also his name is
Philip cloud and it's Philip in the
cloud I you know which just kind of
meant to happen um okay so Ibis this is
a very convinced version of a longer
talk but um Ibis is uh meant to address
um this uh which we all know and love
but there are two main assumptions with
the pi data stack and all these tools
which is that data is local data are
local and data fits in memory uh and
that quickly becomes not true sometimes
um and so what it ends up looking like
when it's when you're dealing with say
pandas and post dress these are just
representative examples I'm not ragging
on pandas I promise um uh we use pandas
a lot uh but what it might happen if
you're trying to get data at a postgress
or snowflake or Oracle or whatever uh is
you're going to connect you have you
know some credentials you ask for a
table you think exists called
ratings uh you slurp up the entire table
from postgress into pandas and then you
you sort of you load it you parse the
types you perform your analysis you're
just all local at that point this works
great until it completely Falls over
right because you only have so much RAM
on your laptop um there's way too much
data there like this this has a distinct
limit of how much data it can
accommodate secondly there's a really
good chance that that thing on the right
the remote engine is much bigger than
your laptop and much more powerful and
also much closer to where your data are
stored so it tends to have a bigger pipe
it can do a lot of things very well uh
and so one of the things that IIs tries
to do we'll skip this and come back is
um connect to something like a postgress
remote ask for that table just get a
schema back a description of the columns
and the data types build up an
expression based on that you can make
certain assumptions like we're adding
two numbers together we're doing we're
performing a string comparison we're
doing some other things generate some
validated type check SQL which sounds
crazy to people and then send it over to
the engine have the engine execute the
query and then only pull back the
results of the
query right so this means that you still
get to do stuff on your laptop you still
get a nice kind of python data frame API
to interact with but we're not just
treating postgress like a glorified data
store because it can do more than that
as Can duct DBS nol postgress you you
fill in the icon on the right there um
this has a couple of uh fun things you
can do like it might be actually
depending on what it's at your local
setup or workplace maybe you're actually
connected to a metadata store that can
be totally SE from the data execution
engine all you need from the metadata
store is a description of tables and
columns and data types um or you don't
care about it at all if you're dealing
with a table that never changes in terms
of it schema just Define something don't
worry about reading this I know it's
really small text but like you define
like hey I know I've got four columns or
three columns I know the types of those
columns you can build up an expression
just on the basis of that and then just
go to execute it on the engine when
you're ready right so this can make for
a much like a nice tight Loop for doing
some interactive exploration and it
means that um to go back a slide I could
have order these
better what it can mean is that you can
bridge this we call the py DAT
translation problem is that very often
the tools on your laptop or in Dev are
different than the tools that are
available in distributed computing
environments Andor fraud and so you end
up doing things like many of us have
probably done like hey I wrote this
thing in canvas but now I need to
rewrite it as like a spark RVD because
it needs to run on this thing over here
or you throw something over a wall to a
data engineer because they need to redo
the data poll because they're actually
doing you know all these things happen
um IIs uh ideally lets you reduce this a
whole lot right because you can write
against like a sample that's local um
build up the SQL query and then that's a
SQL query that can be executed against
the production database and will run
right so we try to stop you from having
to rewrite everything all the time
that's sort of one of the Maines
here I think that might be all the slide
just out of order great okay quick
temperature check um how many people uh
have an environment set up and we ready
to go
is almost almost okay that's close
that's close all right um I will go over
here and we
can
is this big enough for people to see
okay the back there great all right um
I'll Vamp for 30 seconds and then I'll
start uh yes
question forgot what I was Vamp about
how's everyone likeing New
York
there this is the yes go to IIs project
IIs tutorial clone the repository and
there's a command in there for pip and
Mamba to create your environment um yes
brand thought our last presentation for
PTO they also use the Palmer Penguins
data set it's a great data set yes we
love the Palmer Penguins thank you
Alison hor and Alison Hill for
publishing it um it's always nice when
your sample data sets weren't put
together by you Genesis
y That's why you should use
Iris
yes we won't
broadcast
spee
speech
foreign
oh
sorry
feature okay uh I'm going to get started
with this but I'm going to try to talk
slowly and I'll also go over some
general ideas so if you're waiting for
your environment to solve in the
background or things to spin up we
should hopefully get to the same place
at the same
time so the first thing I'm going to do
and you can do to uh is run this first
cell this is going to download
the Palmer penguin's uh database data
set um and then I'm going to load it
into IIs so for this uh tutorial we're
going to be using mostly duct DB duct DB
is an analytical database it's similar
to sqlite whereas sqlite is more of a
transactional database it's designed for
putting stuff in duct DV is for
performing analyses on data you already
have um it's also just a single file
locally makes it very easy us laptop we
like to use it for tutorials and just
honestly for General data analysis it's
really good and very fast um so once you
have a duct DB file um like you will if
you run that first cell you can import
IIs and then uh we can connect to it um
we're only going to be doing analysis on
this so we're just going to treat this
as a re only
connection uh that note you can ignore
because we opened it as a re only file
and I forgot to
this um and then once you're in here you
have this connection you can call list
tables and list tables will tell you
what are all the tables inside of this
database this particular database only
has one table which is also called
Penguins um and so then you might want
to pull that table out so we can begin
to interact with it right now we have
our collection of tables of one table so
you say Penguins equals con. table
penguins that means give me the table
called Penguins just so I say penguins a
lot I'm assigning it into a variable
called Penguins um we'll hit semantic
satiation soon it'll stop making sense
it's fine and we can see that if I just
look at this penguin's variable it says
it's a database table and then it's
showing us the column names and the
column types duck DD is a a you know is
not a CSV file so like these columns
have proper types um that we are reading
in parsing and then say floats in
strings um
so at this point this is just a
representation of a table that's all we
we've grabbed in the database it's just
give me the column names and give me the
column types that's the only
communication we've done so far beyond
what tables do you have um but you might
want to look at the data um so you can
call for instance head like you would in
pandas and then we're just going to add
on an extra two pandas I'll talk about
this in a second that will show you
those first five rows in a data frame um
we also speak with P Arrow quite
frequently um and so similarly to P will
give you those first five rows as a p AR
table slightly less well formatted in a
jupyter notebook but all the same data
and that's the important thing um if you
just call
head you'll see that um you get this
sort of representation of what the
operation is going to do so one of the
things about IIs is that it's a it's a
deferred execution model so as you sort
of call methods on the table um we're
going to build up this expression which
might be you know performing mutations
selections
aggregations uh group buys order
buys and then when you're ready to
execute it we'll take all of that
compile it you know generate a SQL
string or something else and then
execute it so what you see by default
when you do a bunch of methods or just
head is that well you start with a table
and then we said take a limit of that
we're n equals five that's what the head
is it's a select star from table limit
five and
sequal um and it would get longer and
longer for the purposes of a tutorial we
tend to turn on interactive mode which
means we will execute things eagerly uh
for as as much as we have to in order to
show you the first 10 rows just you get
a sense of how the quer is coming
together um so while most of this
tutorial will be interactive hit go it
runs something you get an answer back
just know that that is one way of
interacting with IIs but you can also
build this thing up um much more
selectively without constantly hitting
the database this might matter more for
instance if you're dealing with
snowflake or big query or something that
exists on the internet somewhere and you
don't want to consistently be running
stuff over pipes maybe the lat is a
little
annoying so I'm going to turn on IIs
interactive mode is true and then you'll
see that when we call head it's actually
just going to do the head operation um
and then we'll render it out for you in
a kind of nice table format
um but we're only going to execute as
much as we need to to show you five rows
that sort of video here or 10 rows
actually but we call
head okay so quick primer we've got
tables and we've got colums uh in Panda
land there would correspond like a data
frame made up of
series um so Penguins is a table it's a
collection of one or more columns each
has a specific data
type um so the table we just did that
you see that if you look at the type of
penguins you get a a bunch of stuff but
you see it's a table that's the that's
the the last word is the watch word here
if you look at a single column of that
which we can do by just using an
attribute syntax
here you get you look at the just like
the species column you see there's the
first 10 rows of it if we look at the
type of that you'll see that it's a
string
column so tables and columns tables made
up of one or more columns
um
okay so the first thing we're going to
do is just
start uh interacting with how uh
interacting with this data set a little
bit and just trying to get a sense of
different Ibis operations if anyone's
ever used D plier or vlier and R it's a
very similar
model so the first thing you might want
to do is filter down on the basis of the
values in one column so the way you do
that in IIs is you say filter on the
table and I want to look at only those
uh rows where the species is equal to
adaly um and we'll just take it uh as
rot if that's correct I mean I can't see
what all the colums are but
well um we might want to further add an
extra condition to our filter and say we
also want to look at only those Penguins
who are adal species and live on the
islands called dream so we've got a few
options we can either use an Amper sand
to chain two filter predicates together
and then you'll see that we get only the
aday Penguins on dream now or you can
pass them in as items in a list that
works exactly the same
way um that's just you know what you're
choose your choose your play here um and
just to show you a little bit of what
Ibis is actually doing under the hood
there's always this Ibis Dosh show SQL
command that you can wrap around any um
IIs expression like a this table filter
operation and if you know SQL this looks
probably roughly speaking like what you
would expect right select all the
columns from the table and then give it
a wear where the island is dream the
species is out so that's actually what's
being executed on the duct
T sometimes the SQL we generate will
look much closer than this just a um but
we try to we try to keep it
clean um all right so that's a filter
operation it's common you know way to
kind of drill down into your
data um selection R before this is just
sub selecting a number of columns so
you've got a few options for how you do
this again this is just preference so
you can type out the names of the
columns you already know so species
Islander you can similarly use the um if
you want to use tab completion you can
always use these column objects that are
the attributes of the penguin table like
penguin. species you got the same thing
or you can mix and match that's just
looks weird to me but you're welcome to
do it like this is fine it'll all
work the uh obverse of selection is drop
right so if you want to remove a t
remove columns from a table then by
default we asking for is all the columns
that aren't those columns so you can
drop say sex and year you'll get back
all the columns except those two and
then again just for completion you can
use either attribute um access here or
you can mix and match that's sort of
your choice so that's filter select drop
that gets you to where we
are everything up to now that's all
subtractive we we're either we're
pruning rows or pruning columns um you
can also add things that's where mutate
comes
in um so mutate lets you add a column uh
usually as a kind of a combination of
existing values right so one thing you
might do here um is add a column that uh
converts the bill length from a
measurement in millimeters to
centimeters so that would just be
dividing by 10 and we say mutate we give
the new column name in this case Bill
length cm is equal to Something in the
other columns in the table that we can
then perform some operation against in
order to generate the new values so you
see at the end here we get Bill length
CM which is uh the number of centimeters
in the
bilding um so all of these up to now
that's mate we'll come we'll do a lot of
this um all of those are just single
methods that we're calling on a table
right calling just filter just select
just drop but all of these things that
we're calling they're also returning
tables and so what that means that we
can chain methods as we go right because
you have a table you call a method on it
you get a table back you call a method
on it you call it go and just continues
this way uh and so this lets us build up
more complicated query as we go by
chaining these methods together um so in
this case and this is not the most
complicated query I've ever written but
um we're going to select out four
columns and then we can just drop one of
them that's relatively meaningless but
it just to show you that you can select
them then drop same as you could select
and then filter and then mate and then
drop and you know mix and match the so
you'll get just species Island Bill
length because we've selected four
columns and we've dropped
year
okay so enough of me talking for a
second we'll start with an exercise and
we can also Roam and try to get people
caught up if you're having environment
issues um so we wrote this originally
for a European audience but I still like
it um so your Pi is a cranky American
biologist who thinks the metric system
is for suckers he is wrong um uh demands
we convert all the existing measurements
uh from Mill millimeters and grams to
inches and pounds respectively we are so
sorry about this um and so here are the
terrible conversion factors that show
you just how proster an idea this is um
and so the idea is that we want you to
take this table which has measurements
of uh Bill length and uh Bill wait Bill
length and flipper length depth and
depth yeah Bill length Bill depth
flipper length and also body
mass and convert those into inches and
pounds
respectively um and we want to get rid
of those pesky
metric measurements that make sense and
only leave behind the silly ones that we
use okay I think we're going to take a
look at our Solutions now
um so we suggested two different ways of
doing this that I might have forgotten
to say aloud but hopefully I wrote down
um one is to First mutate which is
create a new four new columns and then
drop the old four old columns you no
longer need so this is how we did this
um so you see we're doing the four
conversions here um I should have I'm
not trying to lead you astray I should
have mentioned you can pass in multiple
things to
mutate um and then we're dropping the
four columns that we don't
want and then that gives us this what
was called some kind of cursive data set
um the other way you can do this so ches
you can use select
directly um which lets you select
columns both by name and you can redo
this part um and then also create new
column sort of on the fly as you go and
because you're selecting you're only
getting explicitly The Columns you're
asking for so while for instance Bill
length millimeter is being used to
compute Bill length in we're not asking
forward in the selection so the only
things that come out on the other end
are those eight columns that we want
um a question we got the last time we
ran this doesn't matter which one you
choose and the answer is really
complicated but mostly no um so if I
show you the sequel for these two things
um you'll see that there's a difference
in how it happens if you do the mutate
and the drop you're actually going to
end up with this this subquery in here
for the first part right here's the
mutate right and then here's the drop
which is selecting out those other ones
if you do the select you get sort of a
cleaner query this is a simpler query
and this does not matter if you're using
any kind of modern SQL execution engine
this will get optimized away and it will
make no difference at all so the
difference is really in the legibility
of the SQL if you're looking at it which
you may not be that would I say that's
like the main difference here I would
say
yes so the question is if you put a sort
of a name Collision inadvertently not
into the selection what happens I'm
pretty sure it might depend on the back
end actually some back ends would
support I think we'll fail on that yes
yeah I'm curious about the SQL that it
generates is it like like the most basic
anql or is it like dependent on the
client connec great question um what is
what is the SQL we're generating um and
is it just basic like anql or is it sort
of I'll say like dialect specific to the
back end so the SQL that we're
generating here is dialect specific so
in the case because this expression is
is built on a duct DB table this is duck
DBC pool you can uh just for fun um we
might have different definitions of fun
uh here say like dialect equals big
query as an
example nope Li don't have big query
installed that would work if you have
the big query black to back and so I
don't have it I have snowflake installed
and that's snowflaking which and
honestly for this query there may be no
discernable difference there
um but yeah by default we show you uh
SQL that you could copy and paste into
like the interactive SQL thing you got
for whatever back end you have but you
can um transpile it into other dialects
that's all thanks to SQL Glock which is
an amazing project we make
have yeah I've got a lot to say about
SQL dialects but I'm not going to say it
because that'll be an hour of me just
random nobody wants that if you do lunch
time um okay so we saw creating some new
columns we've done select filter drop
mutate um so the next thing we're going
to take a look at is order by just
ordering ordering your
results um so the simplest sort of um
way to start with is just ordering by a
single column in this case oh yeah I
didn't we didn't save any of that
Imperial stuff where it's going to
pretend that never happened and go back
to using proper units because I can't
like keep up the facade of carrying
about inches um all right so if we order
by flipper length millimeter what you'll
see is that the flipper length
millimeter column is now the ordering
column for the table um by default
ordering is ascending um we enforce this
so some your back end might have a
different default like when you call
order by maybe it's just default doing
it in descending order whatever it is
will make it ascending by default that's
like something IIs is enforcing on the
back end you want it to be descending
which is a perfectly valid thing to do
you can do either called desk on it on
that column name so that's just being
like so the table column name desk that
sorts it where now that column is in
descending order and that's your key for
the rest of the thing or you
can sub select that because so we're not
looking at a million columns you can
actually see the results so not I'm just
changing order by is Select just to see
The Columns I care
about and then here you can see um you
order by and you can call IIs does
around like the string name of the
column this is just another way to do a
descending order these are all
equip you select out the object care
about and also descending
order okay it's order by um aggregate
we're going to start getting into the
easier stuff here so um Isis has a bunch
of aggregate functions yes question
before we get to the maybe a bit of a
silly question but um can you uh
reference any of the colums without
specifying the actual string is it
possible to reference that by reference
say the last column or the first
colum yes yes there's a complicated
answer there um we'll get to one some of
the ways of doing that there are lots of
ways to select things um in the next
notebook we've got some selectors we can
show you which is lots of ways to do
this but also yeah in terms of like show
me like the the column I was just
operating on as the thing we can you can
refer to that as
well all right so for Aggregates a
straightforward thing you can do with
Aggregates is just call the aggregate
method on the Callum so this is just
what's the mean of The Flipper length
it's going to get back a scalar value
right that's you know we just did the
average of every value in that one
column you get that back um if you want
to compute multiple Aggregates but just
of particular columns you can do that
it's sort of a weird operation actually
but if you wanted to group them together
you can get both the mean of The Flipper
length and Max of the Bild depth in one
command um that's just by passing
multiple of these aggregate methods into
Penguins doag so you can show a bunch of
stuff in there this will make more sense
in a second this doesn't make much sense
um agates by themselves do this they
really start to kind of make sense when
you're when they're paired group eyes
which is when we're going to start
grouping rows that have the same value
for one or more columns and then
applying those Aggregates across those
groups
so if you just Group by a column and
then call A on it or aggregate you're
just going to get actually the distinct
values of that column right yeah there's
no operation of the aggregate so it just
says all right here's here's what we
got
[Music]
um if you wanted to add a second second
column to that group by and then call
add you're going to get the distinct
pairings of the values of those columns
right so here's sort of every uh species
Island combination in the data set we
haven't done any other operation on it
we're just looking at what's what's
available
in um but then you can kind of take it a
step further which is to say like all
right I want to group by species and
Island and then call a on that and then
look at the mean of the bill length
right so we're calling Group by two
columns a mean of Bill length and what
that will give us is that those same
groupings right species island with the
mean computed for each of those
pairs and then this is really easy to
build up into something that's Computing
a lot more s than one go so if we're
grouping by those two columns and we now
pass in a second operation to the
aggregate so we were doing the mean now
we're doing the mean and also the max of
The Flipper length and now we're
Computing both of those things across
all the groups we've created in the
group
I and then there's nothing to say here
that you can't just add more columns to
the group ey if you need to have kind of
uh more um detail or more cardinality in
what you're looking at so if we also
wanted to sort of specify sex as one of
we want to break out it's adding an
extra column here everything else is the
same and we've got the breakouts for all
of the groupings so species Island and
sex and then here are the mean of their
fill length and the max F length across
each of those
groups this is a relatively we think
small amount of code to write to kind of
you know explode out all this
information I don't even know what the
seq for this looks like like off my we
generating might be fun to look at but
we can we can do that
afterwards so uh that's Group by order
by filter tag select mutate drop um
that's sort of like a it's like your
your starting toolkit of uh like tidy
vers verbs is what kind of you know
deepity would call these things sort of
like the the basic tool set so uh got a
few exercises here um just to kind of
try answering instead of us just giving
you a contrive thing you start answering
questions about this data set so one is
what's the largest female penguin by
body mass on each island in the year
so you can think about how you might the
order in which you might want to do
these things it might not even matter I
I think it doesn't but um being like all
right I need to care about what year in
the data I'm looking at I need to care
about what the groups of penguins I'm
looking at are and how I want to break
out the
results um and then same if you want to
look at the largest male penguin by body
mass on each island for each year of
data
collection totally unrelated but I just
learned that if you instead of writing
show SQL you sh you type two SQL it
syntax highlights the output that's
pretty cool I didn't know that sorry I
interrupt please go back to
your don't let me stop you if you're
deep in thought I'm just going to show
our solution to the first exercise and
then I'll give everyone else a few
minutes so here we're filtering by sex
and year to get female penguins in the
year 2008 and then grouping by Island
and then looking for the max of body
mass in the
aggregate you could have gotten through
this a bunch of different ways the thing
you probably want to end up with is a
table that looks something like
this okay we're going to start to move
on
here so for the second exercise we were
looking for largest male penguin by body
mass on each island for each year um and
so that is accomplished by filtering the
only filtering we're doing is just on
the sex of the Penguins and then we're
grouping by both Island and year to get
that sort of exploded view of um the
sets that have those two columns that
are individual and then aggregating over
the max the body
so sure we have data the breakdown by um
Island okay
great um I'm going to run through some
quick extras that don't fit anywhere
else in this tutorial but just useful
things to know about um and then take
temperature and then we can move on to
the next
one so casting uh this is something that
um you'll probably have to do at some
point um especially if you're dealing
with cfvs which are
untyped and will all kinds of things can
happen so if you have a a floating Point
number you can cast integer or vice
versa and so that's just accomplish an
Ibis by calling cast on the column and
then giving sort of the string of the
type you want to cast too so in32 in
this case takes the float column turns
it into an in um vice versa you can um
cast from an integer like the year
column to a float I'm saying this is a
terrible idea not casting the floats
casting your year to a float is a
terrible idea like don't I'm it's the
only integer column in this data set but
that's a that's a bad idea this is not a
number it's a year so a much a much more
sane thing maybe to do would be to
actually cast the year to a string so
you avoid maybe performing numeric
operations on a year you don't mean to
but you can cast numbers to Strings and
you can cast numeric strings to numbers
so if I first cast a year to string I
can then cast that back to an N64 and
that will work because the string 2007
is easily pars inte integer if you try
to cast a string that's like abc123 into
a floating Point number that's going to
error pretty hard um we can't catch that
for you because we're not peeping at the
values we're letting the back end you
that so you're at the mercy of whatever
your SQL back end is going to
be but none of them will convert abc123
into any kind of useful number really
that's never going to go well um however
if you try to cast a um Sor that's I did
here yeah so trying to cast species into
an M32 is going to give you a pretty
pretty long PR back um just telling you
that that's not okay and duct TV in this
case will give you at the bottom of you
know how many lines that was 140 some
odd lines of traceback it will tell you
that it could not convert the string ad
into M32 but you're going to have to
scroll to see
that
um last thing oh yeah drop na um drops
NES from a data set um there are a few
in this one so that just does go
box cool all
right yes drop in a s so if I show you
just Penguins first you'll see hopefully
that there are a few um columns that
have like null values and so um though
any um any row that has any values that
are uh null or n will get removed and
you can be more specific you can pass in
like I only care about NS in this column
only okay so that's what we've have here
uh thanks again to uh Alison Horus and
Allison Hill for the pengu data sets
great um and we'll move on to this
second notebook which is called
um M tables joins and selectors I yes
question can I just ask one question
about in the very beginning of that last
one when we pulled in the dat yes um
that seems to take a while and I'm
wondering what it's doing like it's a
one M file it's clearly doing more than
just loading it is that on the duct TV
side no duct TV is stupidly fast at this
I I think that is probably so the
question for the video is like the first
cell took a little while to to execute
so what's going on um my best guess is
conference Wi-Fi um uh isn't that just a
local F oh sorry this line takes a while
yeah are using the code space or local
environment local
environment I don't know Happ to
troubleshoot that it's not it's
definitely it's on us if it's it's on us
if anything it's not duck they're quite
they're quite fast yeah that should be
very fast I don't know maybe it's just
my weird environment I if it was the
very first time you're importing ittis
if you just created the environment it
could be creating some like doing some B
code compilation stuff in there creating
those you know like pie cash okay
directories like it might just be a
onetime startup thing but generally
speaking that connection call should be
quite quick especially for a local file
okay yeah I was just wondering if it was
doing like doing something to like build
indexes
or no especially especially in this case
because the files actually already been
generated by duct DB so they've got it
there so that's that's uh yeah don't I
ran it again it took zero seconds okay
that's that's that's comforting that
great the second time fast for the
recording okay great yes question back
there um yeah so given his question um
is there some way to control you level
that I has maybe just to check like some
kind of those details if not it's just a
cool idea the question is is there a way
to control level of log and IIs there
isn't we probably could add something
like a
timings uh argument or something if you
wanted to see sort of what what is I
mean we would be limited to like a given
method call and and also what
information we can get from a particular
back end so like I can say you're
connecting to like a cloud database most
of it's just going to be like we're
waiting for something we haven't got it
yet so um but I agree yeah there's more
information we can expose
there oh quick question yes I noticed I
could put in all the arguments into the
egg function itself like egg this by
equals having equals instead of breaking
it into separate pieces yes do we not
like that do we like that not care uh
the question is you can you can pass in
like uh buy and how and a directly
that's just fine um this is just one way
for doing it yeah whatever whatever
unless we unless we said something is
deprecated then it's it's an approved
way of doing things it can be slightly
easier to debug because you can common
stuff out if there's like a big chain
you can me com things out instead of
like
com but it's a perfectly fine way to and
just one question do you support like
cegal data types
on so the data set as categorical data I
will treat as a stram but it will still
use whatever the database
does for like effective efficient use of
category so if you're so if it's like
Arc it's got
kitchen TV or SNF whatever you're using
is almostly going to be using that
taking advantage of that encoding I
doesn't encode any of that information
in this type system so you can't will
cast a column to that specific
representation okay so let's uh start
on start on this um so in the first
notebook we just have you download sort
of a local database file and interact
with it um that's great if you already
have a database file you can download uh
but there are other ways to interact
with data I the first of these are M
tables um so for like a table in memory
uh and there's a couple of ways to
create these so I'm going to import IIs
also pan ases and P Arrow um and I'm
going to set interact mode to True which
again is just for the purpose of this
tutorial you don't have to do that um
and I've got a couple of ways of that
I've encoded some random data here so
here is the first one is is a dictionary
it's the names of some of the August
maintainers and how many commits they
had at some point and uh our aliases
when we go on the Run um uh similarly I
can create a p Arrow table uh where I'm
creating names again of some IIs
maintainers and then pickle count we're
not quite clear I think I think I
decided that was the average number of
pickles we eat per day
um don't remember uh and then a pandas
data
frame um again our names uh if we
committed and then what our first commit
cash was I think I made those up but it
might they might be correct um so those
are just that's a python dictionary a py
table and and a panda's data
frame um and you can create it tables
from each of these just by passing into
M table so that's the dick that's the py
table that's the data
frame you see T1 is the I table
um T2 you can see again I this table I
printed the schema of the P table just
to show you that the py table also has
types and they are string and double and
that gets uh correctly pars into I this
we call it 464 as the same dat Ty though
so with the dictionary we're um
inferring the data types based on what's
there um similarly pandas also has types
um so in the case of object columns
those become strings the boole bus
become booleans but also a table in
I
um then I just had T2 here for some
reason don't know seems like a um okay
so those are me tables that's just a
quick way to like show data in IIs um so
especially if you have like a big data
frame you wanted to use an induct DV you
can do this yes question does every back
end support tables no it does not wait
no maybe most of them do not all yeah um
some of
them there there's all uh I think
there's near Universal um support
especially for small M tables some
backends don't have like a good way for
us to insert random data into them other
than smashing into a huge string and
passing it over a wire so like if you
try to insert I think like you know
30,000 rows in a trino in a men table
it's going to going to take a while
there's better ways I think there
supposed to be better ways to get data
into tro for instance that that is like
a drawback for things like duct DV and
stuff they're peing actually at um
memory in the python session and just
grabbing it directly from there so it's
zero copy and uh very
fast
um okay so we have these M tables we
created T1 t i could name these much
better but um T1 T2 T3 um and now we're
going to look at joints so uh we did
everything previously with one table now
we have two tables or three tables and
often times um data that is interesting
or deeply boring are stored in Separate
Tables and you need to join them
together in order to perform some
analysis based on values there in
disperate tables um so the uh sort of
straightforward joint here is to just do
a to join T1 to T2 and just pass in a
string of the column name you want to
join on so I know T1 and T2 each have
name column you join and you'll get the
uh like a left inner join by
default um for in join yeah
um and because the name uh sorry because
the join column has the same name in
each table you can just pass it as a
string um if they're different or if you
just want want to be explicit you can
also do that and sort of pass in a more
like explicit predicate here and saying
like I want to join from on the T1
column T1 column name name and the t2
column name name yeah name yeah language
design is hard and okay but um yes so
you can perform to join that way if you
were trying to join across columns that
had different names you would you would
do it in this way and just passing the
appropriate column on either side of
that um Quality
um if you have um common column names
besides the column you're joining
on uh that'll create a
collision uh and so IIs is going to
rename those by default for so you can
see here we had a there's a committed
column in T3 and in T1 T1 is on the left
of this joint right t1. jooin so the
committed column in the right gets
renamed to committed uncore right I
think this this is the same behavior as
pandas but my Panda's knowledge is way
out of date
um but you can also specify different
naming scheme depending on how you want
to handle this so you can pass in the
sort of like format string style thing
where we're saying join T1 to T3 on name
and uh specify that the left name pH
Collision should have underscore left in
it sorry um so you see you get committed
left and committed right right committed
right is still B there um or if you
wanted to specify our name we do the
same thing you get right committed
instead of committed right so you can
play around with these that's just this
is just sort of if you're if you're
going to have like a specific uh schema
at the end of it you have control over
how these names get generated and what
happens yes general
question um so the question is is when
you switch from or I IIs or duct TV to
pandas it is up to you one potential
answer is never never I mean like I mean
this is not just like it depends on what
your workload so everything that you're
seeing yeah it can be a replacement tool
for
pandas we're here to play nice with
everybody but um so like when you call
like for instance if I'm not an
interactive you do two pandas that's
going to take this join compile it into
SQL executed on je TV pull back results
and a cursor shove it into a data frame
there's your data frame right I mean
this is just showing me the the first
bit of it but if oh sorry sorry this is
showing me all of it I forgot I have
tables with like five rows in them but
that's the entire data frame in pandas
of this similarly if I do it to py
Aro um I'll get that entire thing back
as a p Arrow table and we never touched
pandas for this except I lied because
one of these tables is actually from
data frame but ignoring that um would
need it yes um in in this scenario if
pandas is the back end uh when you're
when all this is being compiled is the
result uh that it generates is it pandas
operations like or is it it's not SEC
because I know pandas also can par some
sequel but I'm wondering if you're so
the yeah so the question is if you're
using the Panda's back end which is one
of our back ends this will also apply to
the spark back end and the poers back
end and there's one more I think data
commun
um until like a week ago um those
backends until a week ago for data
Fusion didn't accept SE or we weren't
passing SQL in that case uh AAS back in
too in that case we're mapping these IIs
expressions like the thing that like an
order by to some P's operation polar's
Operation it's more of a straight
translation of call the appropriate
method on that thing on the data object
you have as opposed to generating a
squel Varian sending order and follow up
is it possible to extract that result
like to see what those operations are oh
yeah okay the question is can you
extract the operations
um debating whether to show you this now
or later whatever it's maybe a little
bit later do yeah you can see all the
operations going to be executed and
what's going to happen cool cool
um okay but yeah so we we you call
either two pandas or two py if you're
not in interactive mode it's up to you
what format you want that data so you
can certainly use this for your initial
filter aggregation on some massive thing
that's in Snowflake and then pull back
5,000 rows into pandas and continue as
you would from there or into p and
continue as you would or you can keep
going I would say for my part I mean
like snowflake is probably faster than
your laptop so like if you can spell
everything you want to do in Ibis it's
going to be faster until you get down to
what you need and then you want what you
have locally and what you pull back but
if there's something like we don't
support multi- indexes because that's
impossible to do see so so like if you
really want a multi-index like you can
do some stuff then pull it into pandas
and then add that extra index or
something it's up to you when you sort
of switch from one to the other we tend
to try to stay in SQL land for a long
time not because we like SQL so much but
because the engines are really stupidly
fast question um so if you're doing a
bunch of things you're um you haven't
actually run anything yet and then you
run it and then you change something
last step rerunning
everything um question is you like run a
big oper you run like a big command big
expression it gets executed you're like
I have to change something does it rerun
everything um it's going to be I think
the short answer to that is yes um you
can um like each of those like you have
an expression that's like five methods
chain together you can and this comes in
the fourth notebook it's not even here
you can call a cache on that and that'll
create pral backends create a view of
the results at that point and then you
could then continue from there without
repeating the execution but your sort of
the naive behavior is just to execute
from start to front wait front to back
right start to front sounds like the
meaning of the beginning yeah so that's
the typical time I would pull Stu into
something that pandas is when like I
don't want to do all that work yet yeah
so that's when in I night if we're stand
there we just call Cash and then from
there you can continue on and you don't
need to rename your expression just like
that expression is now cash so when you
go to continue from there um it's G to
we'll basically retarget what that
select statement looks like to pull from
The View we just created won cash again
and you call it twice in the same
session so you can call it once run that
a bunch of times it's always going to
used
C and those are temporary views they
they survive for the lifespan of the
connection so you're not like you know
polluting your database with like a
bunch of you know randomly named views I
mean you are briefly but
then just
yes for for local
forting
sendl is that something
ibody in real life you so the question
is if we're if we're passing all the SQL
to snowflake especially if it's Harry SE
we're executing it over and over again
are you going to shoot yourself in the
foot with costs um it's definitely
possible I don't think that the
hairiness of the SQL I mean sorry in
terms of the Genera SQL is going to make
a difference on that that's going to
snowflake wants to execute that in an
optimized fashion also so like that's
going to get optimized down to something
that's much cleaner um but yeah if you
were performing like a like a big query
a bunch like the cost can definitely uh
go up
quickly we can't we don't um we don't
have like protection in place for
that
um okay great questions everyone thank
you appreciate all do
that um so for where were we joints
joints um so default joint is a left
joint rer joint um you can do all of the
other joins as long as the backends
support them sendi empty outer inner
left right um and to do that you can
either just specify the kind of joint
you want in the as a how uh keyword so
in this case this is that like joining
T1 to T3 on name to commit those columns
actually don't match at all so the outer
joints gives you a bunch of
NS super set of those two things um but
similarly this is just again what you
how you want to use IIs you can use like
an outer join method instead so outer
join versus join how equals outer does
the same thing this is just what you
want to how how you want to do
it
um okay uh you can also chain joins this
happens a fair
bit so for instance you want to join T1
to T2 and then T2 sorry then that join
table to
T3 you just call join once you call join
again
um this leads to uh something that I
think we'll maybe address one of the
questions earlier about referring to um
previous operations and how you might
interact with those things
so if we look at T1 join
T3
um if we want to filter on the contents
of committed right this column that's
been created because of the rename right
and IED sorry a filtering operation here
is meaningless because they're all true
but let's pretend that there's something
that we care about um how do you refer
that
column we renamed it for you because it
was a naming
Collision
um so but it's not thank you right Mouse
um it's not part of T3 or T1 it's not
part of either of those tables it's like
it's part of the joined table that was
created part of a new table that we
haven't given a name to right so if you
say like t1. committed right you're
going to get an error because there's no
committed right table in
T1 if you ask for well maybe it's it's
not T free either like neither of those
columns NE of those tables has that
column it exists in this uh like
ephemeral middle
space one option is you can use a Lambda
function this is totally fine just might
I want to write a bunch of Lambda
function so you can say filter on the
results of that join and then look for
some column name committed right equals
true that works um I can prove that it's
actually doing something I think by
saying that the fall and that'll empty
out all the results but writing LDA
functions a bunch can be a little
awkward um so IUS has uh a deferred
operator which we um use the underscore
for um if you're an ithon fan you'll
recognize that this might collide with
the underscore being the history of your
last operation we're cognizant of this
issue and we're sorry um you can rename
it uh I mean it trying to find something
that's that's relatively short to tyght
and easy to do so if this is really
going to mess with your flow we don't
want that you can always import deferred
as capital c or you know pick your
favorite letter um any anything Works uh
Python's very
flexible um and what that lets us do is
in the same way that up above we use a
Lambda function to refer to like the
table that isn't quite a table yet that
has that committed right column you can
use an underscore there instead say
underscore do committed writing equal
true and what that underscore means
effectively is always
everything up to that point in this
expression before the method you just
called so everything in this case before
filter is underscore it always refers to
everything that's
there um and
so in this somewhat hairy looking thing
you can see if I join T1 to T3 and I
rename has committed to committed
right
um and then I can do a filter has commit
equals true so here the underscore is
equal to this join in this
rename
um here I call a mutate on it and then I
start like doing some divisions on
Commit percentage here this underscore
is equal to a join plus a
filter in this last line the underscore
is equal to a join and then a filter and
then UT so it's always everything up to
that
point um so you can always refer
to the entirety of the expression you've
built up up to where you are and then
refer to things that are in there
um and you might not always need to use
this it's just it becomes we've got it
become sort of a very easy short hand
when you're typing just be like
everything up to that point I want to
use this
um uh one way one thing that this comes
up with people get like frustrated with
typing column names a lot and I
definitely get or like table names a lot
is if like you've named your table
variable something
silly um like you can refer to the
aliases column here in this long way but
you could also and that that totally
works it's fine but you can also just
use the underscore and the underscore
here is everything to the left which is
just the table right so this is always
an available
shorthand uh for the table for the the
table expression you have in this case
it does the same thing here the
underscore is just the table represented
by a long name for a
table
okay so the question is the underscore
helps you avoid lots of typing and
refers to the sort of the thing that is
before right is that right yes so in
this case in this case this is just
saving you a bunch of typing really the
left click on this mouse tab is like
this big I'm sorry um in this case it's
just the table name uh in a case like
this it's referring to that join so in
fact there's not really a good way to
refer to the the results of this join in
like in a chained operation if we broke
it up into two lines we could say like
join table equals t1. joint T3 on name
and then we can say say join table.
committed right that's like a a
wellknown that's like a column reference
that makes sense to us but if we want to
avoid breaking up our um expression into
a bunch of individual lines here that
underscore is just saying yeah this is
the contents of that join so I can just
build off of there and keep chaining
methods answer the
question okay
um so now for some data that I didn't
just make
up uh so uh we've got some IMD IMDb data
here um the IMDb data is like a little
bit big uh so we've subsampled it down
to like a
5% sample size so it shouldn't be too
big you can run these two commands to
download those
files uh and then you should
see somewhere oh yeah sorry that's the
thing and I am DB small I believe then
you'll see these two par
files
um so first things first um before we
connected to a duct DB uh Palmer
Penguins thing we just said connect to
Palmer penguin. ddb that was an existing
duct DB database that we had like a SQL
database that we download you connect to
it you can also connect to duck DV and
with an memory connection which just
says I want to use duct TV there's
nothing in there by default but you can
throw stuff in um and that's what we're
going to do here so we're going to start
this inmemory connection and then we've
got some parquet files we want to you
know look at them um so I'm going to
read in those two so in this case I'm
reading in the first parket file I
downloaded and just naming the T I want
to call this you want to give it a table
name of IMDb title
Basics I'm going to read in this other
PAR file called IMDb title rating
and what I was
generating uh you see there's
Basics there's ratings those get loaded
in and you can interact with them like
there any other IIs table at this point
they happen to be backed by a paret file
but once you've done read par you don't
really care
anymore I should say for um people who
are familiar with to this is a view so
if you like delete the parket file then
you care Bic the data is not there
anymore how do you know the size
of how do you know the size um so in
terms of like this size and megabytes on
dis there's not like a I mean I would
use um like d du and Linux for that but
in terms of like the row count you can
um say what this called
Basics
count so the basics table was 479,000
grow is that anyo
equo equal can see how much size it
has um no although it doesn't matter as
much s we the question is like how like
how much space is this going to take up
in memory um this isn't really being
loaded into memory as the thing it's
sort of a trick that way so like du TB
is an outof core uh database so it it
can one of the benefits of using
something like activ here and where it
would perform admirably versus pandas is
that the the limit of the data set you
can load in and operate on is limited by
your hard drive size not how much RAM
you have right because it's very very
fast very parallel and it will drop
things into an out of memory for you to
make that happen it's very good at it um
so like yeah if you've got a one terab
hard drive like you can load a 900 gig
data set and start doing operations on
it and that I mean yeah actually that
should work
but yeah so we don't we don't expose how
much we don't know how much space that's
taken up in memory it's sort of a
fluctuating
thing
um Okay so we've got this basis column
this rting column we've loaded in from
paret file so just a quick exercise just
to uh enforce the join thing which we
want to join Basics to ratings on the
tont column that's the join column here
that's available to us so I'll give you
guys a few minutes for that and then
we'll keep
going question yeah with the um table
objects is it not trivial to do
auto excuse me with the column names of
them yes it it should be available sorry
is is it non-trivial was the question
yes it it is non wait it is Trivial oh
you it is available yes you can do that
yes I just okay I think one of the um
one of the things that happens with the
column names though is that like the
tables also have a bunch of methods on
them and so the table the column names
are in there but so are all the methods
that you can operate on so if you like
know the first letter of the column name
it'll be a lot easier to find it but
like if you're searching for column
names in amongst you know the 40 or 50
table methods it's may not be the
fastest way to get there you can um also
just look quickly at like what are the
column names like if you weren't an
interactive mod you just want to see
what they are it's available as
well
oh follow up is it non-trivial going
with this same premise to use that for
the Deferred underscore operator as
well that is non is it is it non-trivial
to add tab comp to the Deferred operator
the answer is yes it is highly
non-trivial to do that we've thought
about this would be really great um we
we don't know how to do that
you
okay in the interest of time which is
limited um I'm going to move on and skip
a few well I'm not going to skip a few
these exercises but I'm going to run
through them just more of as a demo so I
don't want to I want to have a chance to
show you all we kind of wanted to show
you um but these notebooks are available
as you seen and please do go through
them there's an entire third notebook if
we weren't planning to get to but if you
want to learn more and play around with
some pip guy maintainers data there's a
bunch more um with more Pros as well
since it's not meant to be delivered um
in person I recognize some of these
require person saying like why the hell
is this here um to do this first join
basics. jooin ratings and just say ton
and that's your
join um the second exercise I was going
to do was to have you um join on ton and
then just select out for five columns
here um I just have to run these so I
have the thing working
I so this last exercise is going to care
about sorry so we're going to join a
table and then we want to do is compute
the 10 movies with the highest average
rating who've received at least 100,000
votes that aren't marked as an adult
film so that's sort of the query we have
at hand here um and it's big but we can
step through it and these are all
methods we've looked at right so we are
taking the basics table we're joining it
to ratings on ton so that's our our big
joint table that now has all the movie
titles and the rating and the number of
votes um we're using this helper method
called rename which changes the column
names to be all snake case because we
don't like Campell case names in Python
land um and then we're filtering on
three things one that the title type is
a movie these also include TV shorts and
TV and shorts and documentaries and
other things um we're setting is adult
is adult equal to zero because this is a
family friendly tutorial uh and then
we're specifying that the number of
votes has to be greater than 100,000
because like just because the movie you
made with your friends last week has
like a 10.0 on IMDb it only has the one
vote that it shouldn't be higher than
the sh
Redemption um then we're going to order
all of those because obviously we care
about the ratings being in descending
order by the average rating but have
that descending and then we're selecting
the title and the average rating so we
should get just a list of movie title
and
rating and it should look something like
what you would see on the top 10 and IM
DB but this is
actually not um because this is a 5%
sample right we we we randomly sampled
the titles we were looking at so this is
some top movies but it's not going to be
the top 10 because it's only this sub
sample
um however and this part you shouldn't
run because it only works if you're set
up for this um but
if you have uh for instance snowflake
credentials to come back to our point
about exploring costs but
um which I hopefully
do great I do so I have connected to a
snowflake account here that we've set up
um and you can see that it has tables
called IMDb IMDb title basics and IMDb
title ratings and if you recall when we
read in those paret
files well if you recall there we go
IMDb title Basics IMDb title A same T
same table names right
um if I turn off interactive modes we
can actually look at the expression I'm
going to call unbind which just means
stop pretending to stop treating this
like a duct TV table I just want it to
just be a table like a generic table
object not bound to any particular back
end you can see what we really have here
is like sort of a recipe that's backend
agnostic for how to do what we just did
in duct TV which is we have two tables
here's a description of their columns
and their types we're doing an inner
join we're selecting some of those
columns selecting columns from both of
these bunch of
selections then we're filtering here are
the filter predicates title type is
movie the aren't adult films at least
100,000 votes we're sorting it by
average rating in descending order and
then out of that we're selecting the
primary title and the average rating
none of that is duct DB specific none of
that specific to anything it's just an
Ibis expression that says if you have
two tables with these names and these
columns perform these
operations so if instead of just saying
T pandas or to py I call
actually call
on if I use the snowflake connection I
have which I've just
created and I call that on that
expression then it'll take a second
because it has to call it Snowflake and
then snowflake is going to execute that
and this is actually being executed on
the full IMB data set as of the last
time we pulled it so you notice that
this looks slightly different the top
film is not like as beautiful it's the
Sha Shank Redemption in fact this you
know modulo some temporal differences is
probably the top 10 on IMDd right so we
built up an expression using a local
sample that was only 5% it was very easy
to interact with on our laptops and then
we were ready to go and fire it off we
didn't need to build up the expression
against the full production database
that's unnecessary for our purposes we
had enough to be like does this look
right we can smell check it have I heard
of life as beautiful yes okay then this
is probably in the right direction then
you have the expression then you can
execute that thing against the entire
production big fulls siiz you know fill
in your you know adjective Choice here
database and you're not so your point
about cost explosion you don't need to
necessarily develop against the big
heavy fast thing that's prod you can
develop against something that's a
subsample or a smaller section of it you
can even do that locally depending on
you if you have to make it's your
responsibility or with your database
admin or your data Engineers you have
tables that match you know like you know
the column names need to match the data
types need to match like this is the
Restriction but beyond be on that
there's no difference between running
this on snowflake versus big query
versus post versus duct TV versus S
light versus trino versus I can keep
back and like get all the
same question is there any built-in way
to say like run it on Snowflake and then
say I just really I need a I want a
local sample cat and then I can work
with that and then eventually switch
back to the real thing um you can do
that what I would do for that is I would
say you would like so what I would do I
would connect to snowflake get the table
expression call there's no sample table
sample method right yet on we just add
okay coming up in the next release
there's a table sample method otherwise
if you're okay with a buy a sample you
could do like a like a limit of like
10,000 or something dump that into a pi
into like do two Pi Arrow you have a p
Aro table which you can read directly in
memory from duct TV and then you can
start working with it locally and then
you could dump it to paret to save it
for
later a perfectly viting about that
question is there some kind of extension
API like for example I don't know we're
running everything on Snowflake and we
decided to migrate to some new
technology that just showed up yeah um
and you know I have like the necessity
to implement just part of IIs for that
platform like before you announce like a
production release or something is there
some way for me to implement those kind
of methods
beforehand just
partially um not like in the hacky way
because I think there there are many
hacky so yeah I it it wouldn't be a
hacky but the question is like how would
you implement this for like a flashy new
thing your company is switching to
that's not yet unveiled live as backend
um there is some variable difference in
what back ends Implement like each of
these I don't want to delve too deeply
into internals right now like each of
these Expressions is decomposed into a
series of operations those are agnostic
to backend and then what we're we're
doing is we're mapping an operation like
say take a log of some number to some
base Fe to what would that be in this
SQL
dialect if you don't do the mapping then
when IIs stes to do it it just Falls
over right but if you know that you only
need the seven operations that are in
your new thing you can Implement a full
back end that just has very limited
functionality to begin with uh that re
does require that's like a non like a
non-trivial undertaking unless you've
been in the like in the internals for a
while like but each of these back ends
in the code base are separate you can go
and look at one of them and see what
what's involved I wouldn't say it's
going to be easy but it's very doable
and it would be if you did it it would
be very extensible from there to then
come back in a month and be like I would
like to make this more of a fully
fledged backend not just a trial and add
in all the other operations to the DAT
okay thank everybody for coming I really
appreciate your
[Applause]
time